and you know you are a real fitness
enthusiast you've had to build your body
up you're you know you get involved in
all those martial arts and whatever that
you do have you used steroids absolutely
yes when I was a competing no I didn't
use steroids to do to
performance-enhancing i purely use
steroids when I was younger
pathetic reasons you can't buy ability
in a bottle you get two equally trained
athletes of this up with the same skill
the guy of the the steroids has an
advantage but it's not necessarily going
to win and in the sports I did mixed
martial arts we had heavy drug tests but
yeah I flirted with steroids and lots of
young men I saw Arnie
Sylvester's slow I want to have big arms
like those guys and you can see why
young men want to do that it says it's
frustum singh magazines all the time
yeah I understand
Alex thought that cosmetically they may
give you the look do they physically
give you the strength that that you look
as though you have no and this is why I
didn't like I would never take them for
competition you get in my sport yeah you
can be strong in one plane emotion but
you're being twisted and - and bent and
your ligaments don't get stronger your
your joints your tendons and in as an
athlete that's what you need now yeah
it's all good to have show muscles but I
never wanted show muscles I want to go
muscles so for me that wasn't wasn't
very good Alex is Jackie here does the
sport I just want to know how I get the
message across to young you know maybe
teenage men who want to have the look
that you said that you got from using
them because they're interested in the
here and now they're not interested in
the damage they're doing in the future
of their bodies how'd you get that
message Josh you don't need to look like
this you don't need to take annoyin when
I was young man very impressionable and
I flirted with steroids and I didn't
think like that you you're gonna live
forever you don't realize the
consequences I'm actually say two guys
in the gym now there is a there is a
there is a down to this you know it's
all very well being big and strong now
but it has once you start
mucking around with your nap body's
natural endocrinology you're putting in
testosterone and stuff it affects your
body's natural ability to do that now on
the downside of that I ever had very
very low testosterone and I've went to
see the top endocrinologist in the
country who has actually suggested I go
on TRT which is testosterone replacement
therapy because my testosterone is about
2/3 normal it's 8 to 28 and I've decided
to cut not do that and over six months
I've built my testosterone up to normal
levels again now I love her stressful
life but I wonder how much is that
because when I was younger I played
around with steroids I was going to oh
you know take the steroids when you're
young mmm
you you Mack about your steroid your
body's natural ability to build when
you're older
and you can build a fantastic physique I
see some of the best guys
they've never take I always say you're
on steroids no never take you and I
believe them they've got fantastic
physique
well we can't ever take a story just
they might like set of things out of
there okay so many of us want to ask
your questions Johnny Gold here who's on
our panel Alex I just wanted to ask you
you talked about the long-term effects
on your body which have been subverted
does it affect your mind over the long
term do you find that your cognitive
memories and movement is changed through
drug taking um there's the the
psychological aspect in the specter of I
don't feel I feel small and I feel weak
but I've never had that problem
personally I've quite happy with myself
in fact I've worn a dress once or twice
I don't look very good with big muscles
I want to slow down but yes if if some
people who you know they want to look
big and strong when they're not taking
the steroids they're not going to look
big and strong and that's going to suck
logically affect them they feel I see it
all the time small man syndrome like
women want to be small men want to be
big yeah I'm working on it yeah I'm not
buying everything and Alex really
interesting get in the insight there
just finally and you touched upon it
there but advice to young men in
particular
who
felis is the way to do who want to look
buff we want to look good I presume
you're saying do it the natural way no
actually if if you add when I have I
have taken steroids and when I when I
took them the last time there is a place
for them but you have to be measured by
the doctors having the right blood tests
this is gonna the guys are going to the
gym and they they've talked to Frank the
the gym owner yeah I want to get big and
he's just going to sell him anything you
know that's it that's a dangerous way
when I the last time I did steroids was
about five years ago I had all my blood
measured all my inside so I knew exactly
what I was taking but I did that because
I had a film and always look buff the
second one came off that I couldn't wait
to get off the steroids they make me
feel unnatural and it's okay for a short
period of time so imagine these people
are pumping this stuff in the system all
the time they're going around all the
time
super you know you it's not normal to be
super massive all the time it's gonna it
has sampled so if you can do that
naturally and you can you can't
dimension you don't have to come off the
steroids you're going to be fit and
selfie the whole time of acne drugs and
the big scare for us to go up courses a
lot of people don't know what goes into
these these illegal steroids that we are
highlighting today as well really
everything to get your story Alex gotta
leave it there thank you very much
indeed thank you